[Music]
know where do the powers of good and
evil and chant fans quite like they do
in competition where the hero can morph
into the villain and right back again in
the blink of an eye it's in this arena
that we watch our idols fall from grace
right before our eyes and it's on them
to climb back up the mountain and
e-sports we need not look further than
the Bruce Meister himself he sees them
now they're straight head just they have
no idea
Smith's looking confused and dazed
before and it's
- pretty hard to hold on to divisive
around the world we go over the diffuse
the diffuses
olofmeister has walked the lines of hero
and villain his entire career from
dazzling on the brightest stage and
competing with one of the game's first
truly dominant rosters
kamilly tech champion top phonetic it's
gonna be outside
two facing widespread criticism over a
competitive strat that pushed the games
very boundaries to cementing himself as
one of the greatest counter-strike
players to ever play the game
his is the quintessential counter-strike
story the embodiment of a game loved by
millions sure you may have heard pieces
of historia passing but this this is the
whole story of olofmeister Olaf Olaf
Meister khyber was born in terasu Sweden
on January 31st 1992 as a kid he found
his competitive niche in soccer and
showed a lot of promise as a young
player well he was very talented at
football I remember me my father going
to watch most of his games custody which
path of his life and I think he was
quite good and it was about 4 to 15
years of age it was in the wake of a
soccer injury that stunted his
competitive growth that olofmeister
really started to take counter-strike
seriously and that one injury would
spark what would become one of the most
storied careers in the history of a game
loved by millions when I got injured we
went to a specialist in Stockholm and he
told me that I couldn't play for you I
think he was quite sad sad that he
showed excellent home
really mad and pissed off but I went
actual atonement played a bit it and
construction on that demon olofmeister
started his professional counter-strike
career as a member of team Quinta before
serving as a stand-in for rage gaming in
2010 then came Counter Strike global
Offensive where Olaf first joined forces
with crimson Dennis on LGB eSports as
the scene was first building its base
and during those early days of csgo LGB
quickly became known as one of the
European scenes most prolific rosters
flashing through is he actually gonna
push through this yes he will
this is full of poison definitely one of
those crazy players on this LGBTQ man he
gets to great shots in maybe torrential
third one thousand two one four dollar
poison against the triple killer makes
something exactly all the corner Olaf
built a name for himself on LGB and that
success helped him secure a spot on
fnatic alongside cribs in 2014 early on
in his career Olaf was widely known for
his ability to fill a multitude of
different roles he could wield the
mighty arm looks for the a mate Olaf
gets one he's gonna look for the second
he gets the second as well having a back
up to the box at the back of check up
against the third there's a fourth one
coming in through the fall Oh Olaf he
was a top right Fuller walk nice made
him cover to cover the top there able to
pick up aster has been just a great
player for LGB and he could clutch with
the best of them so much so that he will
go down in csgo history immortalized on
the walls of overpass
around the world we go for the diffuse
the diffuse is coming in we could do it
all and that's what made him different
he have grown into his role within the
team and so I think he have always been
capable of being the best player in the
world and obviously that's why we picked
him up it didn't matter who we played or
what tournament it was it was always one
in our team that played like the best
player in the whole world in that first
year together fnatic cemented themselves
as one of the best csgo teams in the
world they want a slew of small events
and finished second to NI p at the
year's first major ESL one cologne - on
5jw and flusher there is nothing they
can do any longer ni p have won Gamescom
2014 ladies and gentlemen 1613 it
finally happens but Olaf's rise was tied
to the end of ni peas historic run
through the early days of csgo and it
didn't take long for fnatic to become
the undisputed best team in
counter-strike 1 the fans loved and
loved to hate of any event in 2014 it
was at Dreamhack winter where
olofmeister showed the kind of player he
would eventually become putting on a
show
only a superstar could scientist cloud9
is trying to see if they can get a
little bit more damaged on all of my
says there though pretty clean pickoff
has two results of the cset for the
third kill in a row here in these kind
of lollies got one person down a
long-tailed now is full of meister and
he's just landing some really nice shots
so not even any chance I mean the bomb
actually fell down into CT spawn but
just as olofmeister showed his greatness
the counter-strike world turned its back
on it
more than anything they're gonna need to
simply win this pistol and they are
playing a pretty standard game of though
do they have a weird first going on
currently yes my god I just think it
wasn't fair
well it's definitely not fair should
have your move he sees them down there
straight and just they have no idea
without their did three it's just
shameless of them they still I'm not
sure Nexus getting fired
I definitely can't just go unquestioned
there it is rainy you're never gonna
gather the boo stuff not opaque but also
wind Z - hold on back in 2014
cheating was a problem in counter-strike
young players and prodigies alike were
looked at with harsh scepticism and it
felt like most were seen as cheaters
until proven innocent so to say this
incident occurred at an inopportune time
would be an understatement heading into
the bracket stage their quarterfinal
matchup was against ldl-c a French
roster many considered to be the second
best team in the world behind fnatic and
they quickly fell behind
so Happy's gonna be able to rotate very
quickly and be right on the edge of that
smoke so it's fnatic come through this
kill is going to be crucial but it looks
like olofmeister just barely stays alive
q mind the meantime he's got the scar 20
surprise surprise yet still makes it
three and this is it's about to be
lights out for phonetic there isn't a
whole lot of overall high storage an HP
shocks you all have down and
the first half of this mess of three but
Olaf and fnatic bounced back on cash
prices got this perfect you figured out
very nice way here turn 16 to 8 and
phonetic bring us on to a third map
that's gonna be overpass what a
quarterfinals this is exactly what we
ordered exactly what we needed here
until tragedy struck in map 3 where they
found themselves down 12 3 on overpass
it is really terrifying at the moment
here pistol round means everything
otherwise phonetic could end up crashing
out of this quarterfinals essentially in
the final map that would be a
devastating result for them obviously
home turf here there's gonna be a
serious discussion going on right now
on the phonetic side about how to
approach this pistol round because it
has to be one it was then that Olaf and
the rest of fnatic deployed the single
most iconic boost in counter-strike
history prettiest and the game of oh do
they have a width roost going on
currently yes oh this is beautiful
Drew's as well he sees them now they're
straight headshot they have no idea
Smith's looking confused and dazed and
it's gonna be a
they still have no show Nexus getting
fired round after round the boost worked
to perfection there it is it's rainy
down death to Apollo I'm not gonna do
too much damage but down is superb it's
going down the pain continues it's again
here they're trying to see if they could
potentially get a cleaner shot look at
this now happy getting boosted up but he
gets spotted all eyes for sees it coming
they have accounted for this but I think
they're one step ahead the end is near
it's five on three and fnatic have
summoned an unbelievable comeback they
pull up an ace up the sleeve and they do
it for just every single round there on
out flush against the double and it's
down to Smiths no chance at all phonetic
they make their way to the semies of
another major tournament here
16:13 from the brink of failure fnatic
unveiled a gamebreaking strat to get
themselves back in it and it worked
better than anyone could have thought or
so it seemed until a series of rulings
traded back and forth between the two
teams
Olaf spoofs was placed under review and
the match was set to be replayed the
next day after hours of demo review is
they found that both Smith's and Olaf -
boost took advantage or or were subject
to this one texture bug that that could
be applied to both of them and so they'd
found their way to just say both of you
are at fault actually and so we'll
replay then in a decision that is still
unclear to this day fnatic forfeited the
match - ldl-c
and overnight became the villains of
csgo it's that hivemind right of the
community
everyone hopping on that bandwagon of
disliking fnatic at the time was kind of
the cool thing to be doing it was like
such a low low point I mean I have had
much hate through through the whole
career pretty much as he's going but
this this thing was just like it was so
much at the same time and it was very
very hard for for me as well as the
others regardless of your thoughts on
the Olaf boost fnatic entered 2015 as
the best team in the world whether the
fans liked it or not and heading into
the year's first major they looked
unstoppable everyone expected them to
win
ESL one Katowice and they didn't
disappoint
I'll go to the hands of JW get right
going for the neck cut off Meister with
a headshot picks him off and this is the
moment pick games require big players
does that pump goes down and then IP
attempt yeah another retake Scooby free
phonetic that getting these palm punches
they just need one more round and
they'll be able to do it all of my sty
Kent hiding in the same spot up my
graveyard and Crim's buddies in the side
oh there it is now it's on exist 1 V 2
here financing they could be the second
or the first teams win a second
championship here on global Offensive
and Oliver West's playing it so safely
they know that they have it exist gets
one and he's back on it he's got the kid
he's holding it down I'm not sure
there's enough time for an out ladies
caminito champion phonetic fnatic didn't
drop a single map until the finals of
Katowice and olofmeister was named the
tournament's MVP despite the fact that
the hard feelings from the community
still remained post Olaf boost Olaf
himself seemed to revel in the eyes of
his critics he only got more accurate
became a better leader and filled every
role fnatic needed him to quite simply
he'd reached a divine status in game and
he wasn't about to let anyone take that
away from him what followed for Olaf and
fnatic will go down in counter-strike
history leading up to the year's second
major fnatic seemed unstoppable and
looked primed to be the first team ever
to win back-to-back majors as ESL one
cologne s group stage got underway
fnatic and Olaf looked as good as ever
all of my C's already somehow snuck all
the way up through connector into all
jungle gets the kill gets the four max
let's see if you can get more he does
manage to get more flushes also taken
down groovy and now two men remain here
for e battle this is a perfect position
for all of Isis analysis that there's
the wall man taken down low it's now all
unfurl and sixteen rounds to two an easy
day at the office really for fnatic
trying to make the rotation crews Pro X
all pushing in on site as seized single
has
people up they add eagle a dream it will
be
believe me single tap down and that is
it ladies and gentlemen it was all too
easy for fanatic 16 to as they
absolutely decimate the opposition in
their groups but it was in the
semi-finals that fanatic were met with
their fiercest competition virtus Pro
Ward's like JW down cribs all Antonio to
do what seems impossible just be 110
seconds the bomb is a priority he's
gonna be punching the digit sitting now
with the dowdy to play for pronax saves
the day with two and oh my god is this
an intense semifinals max he's waiting
if Olaf jumps off here he is a dead man
walking
let's see what he does patience may be a
virtue flash comes out here we go is an
absolute mastermind is to appoint one
make two flashes as he knows that three
he's mostly point the ball and just keep
bragging that he gets thrown acts but
cribs at all are alive and now snacks
and neo have to do everything to keep
virtus pro chances at the grand final
alive it's all on me oh look at this
place one three to thirty seconds
crusher phonetic
seaside in a hard-fought match fnatic
would once again show the world why they
were the best but whether it was because
of their dominance or some residual hate
from the Olaf boost the team received as
much hate as they did love from the
community that was stressful it was
emotional to watch what was it like to
play come on
there's only great games say we don't
have food any sports no Goonies boss
Olaf talk to me what was it like to play
in that match it was a great thing to
watch hardly mentally to clean up camera
come on guys it was a great match she
has to cheer for both teams in great
matches like that told me through what
was it like to play was hard to mentally
to play that game but guys please
respect for the finest second fine that
his piece respect them and after that
win their Finals matchup against envyus
wasn't in doubt she think about going
for the challenge here and all up not in
his lifetime
Kenny s just smokes you off but flushes
not having anybody's gonna push off
through he's gonna come down Kenny and
Kier Shiva now all alive into the
crosshairs of all of my stuff just lines
up the shot gets the supporter flusher
and this will be fantastic
taking map walk on us to 1950 this
little bit of speed coming into it here
grenade on through and envy the speeding
up kW missing a couple of shots and they
catch two and return pronax on the back
lines and they're gonna get a refresh
here very low in health is happy and
they just keep on training it's true
they can't stop now all off with a kill
as well it's gonna be Kenny with refract
reneedar in Happy's on six health and
ladies and gentlemen it's gonna require
a miracle and nothing less for happy to
make it out I don't think there's any
chance flusher looking to end this it's
gonna be
a third major championship in global
Offensive to this day fanatics run in
2015 is one of the more impressive feats
in the history of eSports that year the
team brought home a whopping 10
international titles and became the
first team in counter-strike to win
back-to-back valve sponsored majors they
were an absolute juggernaut and at the
head of the ship was olofmeister with
the 2016 season underway many expected
much of the same dominance from fnatic
and Olaf and the season certainly
started off that way 3 us is for right
now this is looking great for fnatic JW
taking that kill us while falling and
cold Sarah it is a 2-1 for right now but
can they possibly retain this it seems
almost impossible they're gonna try and
take that time fall and goes down in
there
phonetic right Intel Extreme Masters
season 10 winners
[Music]
ten years of history that said their
strong start didn't last CS goes
competitive scene was exploding around
this time and teams like luminosity
looked primed to dethrone fnatic at 2016
s first major MLG columbus fnatic placed
second in their group but this time
things felt different throughout the
event Olaf was plagued with an arm
injury and fnatic were stunned by an
upstart team from Denmark as a
three-pronged assault from Australis and
there we go crimps gets taken down and
stay doubly left it's match point for
Australia a double he needs to clutch
we've seen it before we need to see it
again he needs to play out of his skin
for his people survive it but there's
too many angles too many Estrada's
players zero into two fnatic oh
astronomy but I don't know I watched a
week or two weeks before I started
feeling something was wrong in my race
and I got super like I was like I kept
playing for what like one day and like
something is wrong like I need to take
some days off and didn't get better and
like so basically we had no practice
before going to the made it and if it
was a normal tournament I was just
saying I'm not playing like I need a
break but I couldn't like because you
can't change in the players I couldn't
leave so I had to play and I I'm I self
a little bit shortly after the event
fnatic dropped out of the upcoming
Dreamhack Malmo [ __ ] off Meister took
an extended break from pro play two
nurses injury olaf would then return to
the fnatic lineup in order to compete at
the year's second major but the magic
just wasn't there
causing problems he's gonna win an
important tool but he's heavy tank as
well everyone's tied for the t's now can
they get up on down as a player sighted
Mitro he's putting in words hunted all
across the remaining that don't say near
everyone status just one of my select
versus two he's got up to on the bond
but he's got 30 seconds to do it to a
cave smoke said JW isolated fighting
around the focus area rims is the last
man to keep fanatic witness he has so
many players to take down two of which
are very low
there's the first one he gets
immediately tagged in the face this is
so terrible right now / Crim's there is
a fanatic just weren't the team they
once were
and neither was olaf something needed to
change in a massive roster swap during
the back half of 2016
fnatic sent JW flusher and Crim's to
godsend in exchange for twist and lek
row at a glance the move looked like an
attempt to rebuild the team around Olaf
to make another push at becoming one of
the best teams in the game once again it
didn't work
hitting him on the other side but now
conflicts coming from the same angle
that's Reuben with a shot and electrons
to come over the bomb and that's it
Dignitas they're gonna be in the semi
finals here at epicenter Moscow verses 2
to 5 which is on the workout mix wall
full health versus jumping hey Kate
versus a que no kid on jumpy continuing
to run will you charge straight through
the door he will off tick perceived
fnatic eliminated 16 to 11 almost as
quickly as the move happened at the orgs
decided to switch their players back to
their original teams
unfortunately that reunion led to more
middling results placing inside the top
three only once before an early round of
eight exit from 2017 second major at pgl
Krakow gambit playing is so small they
understand the timing as well they
understand exactly how JW might move
around the map as we can see a trend
making his way towards teammates dude
are we going put it all back and there
you go
make it work 16:14 give us very cool
isn't it
however hope is still holding down the
position grammar so takes down over
disco for sure though too weak to HP and
now he's dead on the bomb site then in
one of the biggest roster moves in the
history of Counter Strike Olaf left
fnatic we tried everything in fact I
could write so many different lineups
and I was just I felt it was a good
timing and also face at that time we're
a lot better team that we were than I
was just I needed something you need a
new motivation and I felt like I got it
from a yarn face in addition to
acquiring Olaf faze clan also signed a
star offer Guardian to pair with the
likes of Nico rain and Kerrigan this
iteration of faze clan were immediately
thrusted into the limelight and heralded
as quite possibly the greatest super
team in counter-strike history
olofmeister was once again at the center
of the csgo zeitgeist but playing on a
team of superstars represent a new
challenge for the first time in his
career he wasn't his team star player
instead he would have to operate as a
secondary Fragger behind Nico and rely
on his strong fundamentals to make an
impact this move would be a testament to
Olaf's legacy as a player because if he
could make this work then there wasn't
anything he couldn't do this information
though now phase are gonna pounce they
know that they can push on to this site
that there were two players there for us
draws the flashes in it's good
olofmeister takes out debris now they
know where the remaining players are
coming from
it is over six out of five HP and it's
not gonna be enough 67 when phase has
done it they are your elite champions
names ray Harrison ultra where the
firebox and hope of a kill all in one
position and Guardian makes it back to
the time the flash and Nico fittingly
gets the last killer's face dominate New
York in 2017 the Barclays Center all the
way through this tournament course it's
sunny but rain there's no winner took
for him they can't trade either brain of
course for versus to doing more damage
leaving Oscar for UMP it's gonna pick up
a rifle surely go positive next area
this is the end of the line for
mousesports face off the hidden passage
best of three shut down the dreams
desires of passports and take the
championship they came into it as the
favourites and finally they prevail
phase were firing on all cylinders come
the Boston major and looked unstoppable
in the new legend stage going as fast as
he can all of my sagessa sound cues and
he's gonna have the angle even if there
was time which I don't think there is my
some debris fire there and though there
is a time to watch because unfortunately
16 to 8 is the score line and that was
pretty much all faze clan otherwise
he'll lose by time of course he can't
plant it so he has to somehow close the
distance to the bottom they go for a
plan and so hot key dominant absolutely
crushing showing from fence just
cancelling all of that I think you got
flashes well actually from the other
side so time is running out
Jarrod's been 1612 phase made their way
to the playoffs yet again in a major
tournament they then made quick work of
no sports in the quarterfinals and it's
just ROPS
young Estonians first time in the
playoffs
he's certainly impressed but it's not
been enough the mouse is bit the cheese
the trap is closed to nothing for phase
they'll move through to the semi-final
and our favorites move on before
reminding simple and natus Vincere why
they were the scenes most feared team
from zeus to hold off as well because he
knew CT put in them so the vet was next
light but less likely I should say what
a shelf of Guardian words out of my
mouth as he nails it through the box he
is tagged up smoke on the ball
immediately he's got the kick that's no
like to hold on and there they sat one
of the most decorated teams of
superstars in cs:go history staring eye
to eye with cloud 9 the scrappy
underdogs who clawed their way to the
finals this is the final boss this is
the phase roster just look at this
Talent it is so status because if you
look at meetings this yet when they
played each other you can see cloud 9
have certainly not had the best of it
phase clients seem to be their
kryptonite I think the problem here is
the fact that you know phase not only
won the last three encounters in the
best of three - I know it's in such a
dominant fashion as you guys can see
only double digits two times while I
explained super well but
[Applause]
to play like that after splitting the
first two maps cloud9 in phase found
themselves in a winner-take-all showdown
on inferno well they left open
coordinate may have been a mystery
because in the codes cloud line but all
spice has something to say three kills
that's a great defense from him and
Guardian starts to get in on the action
as well but tarik the only man the last
line of defense for the B side sir be
stopped by all of Meister and is a cave
this distilled a good Olympic alpine
nothing else is going on he's got to go
back
Stewie's on doodle repositioning after
the first frag it's both now from quad
river face can can't like close it
skadoodle gets one skadoodle card get
the third it sneak over 12 is there time
Oh is there time I'm not sure if they're
it's gonna be a close one
I need my net so from this position
before you cannot miss a single shot
Guardian waits patiently as crowd my
scepter push up
[Applause]
a major champion
while celebrated as one of the scenes
greatest underdog stories the major
ended in heartbreaking fashion for the
European super team and as the Sun set
on Boston it was back to the drawing
board for phase their heartbreaking loss
aside the phase Olaf experiment was by
no means seen as a failure
they had a great showing at the major
and were still counterstrikes darlings
in the minds of many but what would
transpire in the coming months would not
bode well for them phase chained their
second place finish with yet another
runner-up spot at IEM katowice they were
then dispatched in the quarterfinals of
2018
second major where they watched astralis
become the dynasty team they'd hoped to
be
[Music]
[Applause]
in the wake of the London major phase
and Olaf had fallen from a consensus
contender to a team with a lot of
question marks in December the team
decided to bench a longtime in-game
leader Kerrigan after Nikko took over
the IGF responsibilities no matter what
happens with phase and olofmeister in
2019 one thing is certain he will retire
as one of the single greatest players in
the game's history no one will ever
forget olaf on fire
the infamous olaf boost the major titles
and his ability to transcend controversy
and never back down from competition but
there's another story to be told
if faze can flip the script in 2019 if
olaf is able to rebound and challenge
astralis on the major stage of god of
counter-strike will rise again and
that's what makes Olaf's career just so
amazing with every blow he finds a way
to bounce back with even more ferocity
olofmeister has redefined what it means
to be great because even when the crowd
roared for him to fail he was merely
fueled by the adversity and in 2019 olaf
is the underdog once again
[Music]
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]